[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back hot ones fans I missed you
so much this is sha Evans checking in to
say Happy New Year and to let you know
that my resolution this year is the same
as it's been the past 8 do interviews
and smoke out celebrities but to do that
I need the help of my partners in crime
the spiciest Supporting Cast in the
entire business and that is the hot ones
lineup new year new season new sauces
here it is season 23 if you can believe
it in all of its glory and to kick
things off after a stellar rookie season
hot one's original buffalo sauce is back
hot one's buffalo sauce returns with
mild Cayenne Tangy vinegar and real
butter none of that fake movie theater
stuff around here it was a big hit with
guest in Season 22 it has my seal of
approval but most importantly it's been
stamped by our own resident buffalonian
camera guy Bill that's all the
validation I need all right moving on
here to Sauce number two please join me
in welcoming to the hot ones Gauntlet
Chef Sam with his concoction Smokey J
Sam SAU is a supremely smoky sauce made
with Cherrywood smoked jalapeno agave
and a hint of cumin you know what they
say where there's smoke there's fire and
that leads us rather poetically to Sauce
number three another newcomer to the hot
ones table this is funky Stellar fuzz
this one brings a little bit of sweet a
little bit of savy to the party and it's
all cranked up with the fruity heat of
habanero peppers we always love a little
pop in the three spot and then this one
has a lingering heat that's balanced out
with ginger garlic and a little bit of
apple cider vinegar
chef's kiss all right on to number four
I know it's winter but the sauce of
Summer returns like a weekend getaway to
the Caribbean in the middle of January
it's here hot ones Los
centes tart ttio sweet apricot and
smoked serrano peppers it's a hit every
single time now every once in a while we
have a sauce that'll just stop guests in
their tracks and this one in the Five
Spot is our version of that in season 23
as strange as bizarre as unique a hot
sauce as we've ever had on the show say
hello to the halfway mark and queso s
queso it took years of recipe
development but Chef Maxim from good
heat has made a hot sauce that mimics
the spicy Rich deliciousness of queso
and it's all done without any dairy it
is vegan it is delicious it is
completely Bonkers like imagine dipping
a wing in the tastiest nacho cheese
sauce you've ever had that's kind of
what we're going here in the number five
spot with queso seso will be definitely
a conversation starter in the lineup
this season and then moving on back like
they never left our friends from Cantina
Royale they were here in season 15 and
they are back here in season 23 bourbon
Maple Reaper and the six spot two things
you'll love to see in a hot sauce name
one that maybe you don't but it's the
back half this is hot one season 23 we
have to crank things up and Notch Reaper
will do that and speaking of cranking
things up a notch moving on to Sauce
number seven and a sauce that took years
and years to develop and finally it's
here straight out of Montreal forbidden
fruit is another sauce that's taken the
Scoville obsessives at laot pentary
years to perfect forbidden fruit special
mix of peppers they've been fermenting
for months leading up to season 23 and
now is this sauce's time to shine all
right moving on to number eight the most
chaotic hot sauce in the history of
chicken wing talk shows it's the bomb
Beyond insanity and it is back for
another year of Mayhem when it comes to
the Democracy of smoking out celebrities
there are no term limits when you
perform at this level for better or
worse to bomb Beyond Insanity stays I
know that there are some of you who
click on this video just to see if the
bomb's there well here it is all right
we are almost to the top of hot sauce
Mountain Chile monol Loco back with
another nine Banger at number nine T SOS
is a secret mix of super hot peppers
lemon and vinegar a classic Hot Sauce
maker last in the lineup in season 12 we
are so happy that they are back here in
season 23 and with another nine spot all
right and here we go on to the summit of
Mount Scoville the last dab experience I
can say this now officially made with
pepper X the Guinness World Record
hottest pepper in the entire world you
saw what it did to chili clouse so just
a imagine what a sauce made from 91%
pure peppera will do to your favorite
celebrities and there you have it in all
of its Glory it's the season 23 hot Ones
hot sauce lineup you know the drill if
you'd like to play at home that's
heatness.com heatness.com heatness.com
to get your hands on the season 23 hot
one sauce pack and to close things out
my guess is if you're still watching
this video the season 23 hot sauce
reveal and you've stuck with us till the
end you already know what's coming next
season 23 the premiere of hot ones is
coming next week thank you so much for
supporting us and allowing us to do this
for 8 years 23 Seasons very excited for
another season of hot ones our 23 our
Jordan season we'll see you next
[Music]
week what is up spice Lords camera guy
Bill here back in the studio for hot one
season 23 you know it you love it you
want to watch it so be sure to like And
subscribe for all the latest and
greatest hot ones content and uh see you
on the
premiere